ん
[音楽]
うーむ空港
今日は数学とは何かについて皆さんと考えたいと思います
小学校中学高校ではすべての生徒が数学を学びますしもちろん皆さんも数学を学ばれた
と思いますが
数学とは何かについて考えられたことはあるでしょうか
数学は苦手といわれる方が多い一方
公式をたくさん覚えて計算するのが数学といった印象無償の方も少なくありません
皆さんはどうでしょうか
数学とは何かという問いに対してすべての数学者が一応に答えるわけではありません
しかし
公式をたくさん覚えて計算するのが数学だと考える数学者は真島さん
このように考える人にとって数学をすることはかなり苦痛なのではないかと思います
やはり数学の本質とかけ離れたものを
数学だと思い込むのは
数学を学ぶ会で大きな弊害となります
そういった意味でも数学の本質について考え理解することにはいいがあると思います
今日は数学に関するアイスター員とハーリーの言葉
また私たちは数学において何を探求するのかについて気にし
数学とは何かを考えたいと思います
アンシュタインは
数学は
論理的概念の子であると言いました
私はこの表現が好きで皆さんにもこの意味を考えていただきたいと思います
まず論理的概念という言葉が示すように
数学は
論理的に厳密なものです
一方
数学のもう一つの重要な要素が
数学は子であるという表現に示されています
これは数学が創造性にあふれもうであり
芸術的でもあることを意味しています
皆さんにはローンり的にゲームつであるということと
創造性にあふれもうであるということは
相反するものに映るかもしれません
しかし数学においてはこの2つの要素が高度に
互いに扇な焼いた亀有ます
残りの時間皆さんもこの愛妻の素晴らしい言葉を実感されるのではないかと思います
では私たちは数学において何を探求するのかについて考えます
数学は数字を探求するものと思われるかもしれませんが
数学には数乗扱わない分野もあります
もう少し普遍的なものを考えることが数学の本質を理解する上で重要です
数学者ハーリーは
数学者とはが家や詩人のように
構造を作り出すものである
と述べ数学は構造探求するものであると言いました
この言葉が示すように様々な構造を作ったり
見出したり使ったりするのは数学の根幹となります
皆さんにとって数学でどのような構造を探求するのかよく分からないところもあるかと
思います
5に示されているパーツ館3関係を使って数学で扱う構造について考えその過程で数学
の重要な特徴を見出したいと思います
この三角形は様々なところに表れます
例えば皆さん学校で
x + y の2乗は x 以上を出す2x y + y 2条東
学ばれたと思いますが
その係数もこの三角形の3行目に現れます
まあ今日はこういうことを話すのはやめましょう
驚くほど多くの構造がこの三角形には含まれており多くの重要な数学の概念を学ぶこと
ができます
一つかなり分かりやすい構造があるのですか
皆さん見つけられますか
おそらく最もわかりやすいのは左右対称であるということでしょう
左半分に現れる数字が右半分に同じように現れます
あと電マで触れますが対称性は重要な構造です
各1で数字がどのように決定されているか分かりますか
まず左辺と右辺上の数字はすべて1です
その他の数字はその上の二つの数字の前になっています
例えばには1+1
さんは医師たちに6はサンタさんです
この三角形は限りなく続くものですがこのように構造を理解すると数字を覚える必要が
なく頭の中で後簡単な計算をしながらこの三角形を作ることができます
ポーズを理解し使うことの重要性がわかる簡単な例です
ではこの三角形に現れる機数が作る構造について考えます
最初の休業に現れる奇数
135南東ですね市がここにしろで示されています
このように
奇数が現れる1に着目すると面白い構造見つけることができます
皆さん想像力を働かせて
128行からなる巨大なパスカルの三角形を頭に描いてみてください
これが急遽ですから128行もあるとかなり大きなものになるはずです
その128行に現れる奇数の位置がここにしろで示されています
このずには明らかに構造がありますがみなさんはその構造を言い表すことができますか
まず大きな三角形がありますがよく見るとその三角形が3つの少し c 3三角形から
成り立っておりさらによく見るとその小さな三角形の一つ一つ
例えば今三角形が
3つのより小さな三角形から代だっています
これが据えていきますね
専門的にはこの構造はフラッターの一種で
全体の構造がその構成文の構造と同じになっておりこれを自己相似と言います
フラクタル構造は海岸線植物
継承内蔵の内壁など自然のあらゆるところで乾燥してきます
このフラクタル構造を覚えておいてください
終わり近くに意外なところで出てきます
キリがないのですが数学者としては皆さんにお見せしないと罰があたるような構造が
ここにありますので紹介します
このように三角形に斜線を引きそれぞれの射線上にある数字の和を求めます
最初の車線のは1
その人が車線-1-1
その次の車線の y にですね
これを続けていくと高校に示されている数列が笑います
これはフィボナッチ数列とバレ
多くの数学的分析に現れる重要な手術です
先ほどのフラクタルとどうよこの数列も自然に存在する構造を記述するのにとても有効
です
例えばこのフィボナッチ数を一辺の長さに持つ正方形を
このように
並べます
とてもきれいに並びますね
何故このように綺麗に正方形を並べることができるのか
家に帰ってぜひ考えてみてください
これを使ってできる螺旋は
自然に存在するさまざまな構造
例えば
貝殻
ギンガー
台風など効果的に表すことができます
このように良いパスかあさんが計を少し数学的に考察するだけでも多くの構造を
見つけることができます
もちろん数学には多種多様な研究対象がありますが
どの数学の分野においても何らかの形で
構造を作る見いだすあるいは使うことによって物事を理解し数学的診療を確立していき
ます
このことを理解することは数学の本質を理解する上で重要です
またここで数学の重要な特徴のいくつかを見いだすことができます
私たちはパー4巻参加型を考察していて
フラットある
フィボナッチ数列乱戦を見つけました
他にも多くの構造を見つけることができます
このように
一見何の関わりもないような様々な概念
構造が
深いところで結びついていることが数学においてはよくあります
そして
これらの多種多様な概念構造とその関連性を真に理解するためには
厳密な論理的思考と豊かな想像力の両方が必要です
いくら想像力が豊かな人でもターンに想像することによってこれらの概念が結びついて
いることを認識するのは不可能でしょう
また
ローンリジィ思考だけでは
これらの概念を発送することはできません
アインシュタインがいう数学は論理的概念の子であるということを実感できるのでは
ないでしょうか
またここで数学の不思議な特徴
見いだすことができます
それは数学が自然に存在する構造を記述するのに驚くほど有効であるということです
ガリレイは自然という書物は数学で書かれていると述べ
ファイマンは
数学を理解しないともっとも深遠な宇宙の美しさを理解することは難しいと述べ
また wigner は自然科学において数学は理不尽なまでに有効であると述べまし
た
線化学工学において数学が二ヶ月ある麺です
では最後に数学と日について考えます
先ほど紹介した数学者ハーリーは
数学の概念を評価する際に最初に間にするべき点はその概念が美しいかどうかである
伴目
醜い数学が存在する余地はないとも述べました
ここに数学の本質において不可欠な要素である
美の探求が言い表されています
このことについて考えます
まず b 辞退について考えることが必要です
みなさんはどういったものを美しいと思われますか
美しいと思うものを想像してみてください
富士山は日本人にとって特別な存在だと思いますが
穴山を見てなぜ私たちは美しいと思うのでしょうか
美しいですよね
明らかの特徴としてこの山はどの角度から見てもほぼ左右対称です
数学的にはこれは中心軸に関する
回転対称性として表すことができます
また山の輪郭がとても滑らかですかこれは数学的には
曲線表す関数とその微分可能性によって表すことができます
少し難しい専門用語が並びましたが
これらは先ほど考察した
数学において探求する構造です
これらの特徴概念は
b と結びついているのでしょうか
近年我々の審美眼に関する様々なかがって研究が行われており
数学と日の関わりも解明されつつあります
ある研究では
同程度の例であるを持ち数の中で美しいと認識された画像のデータ圧縮性が高いことが
示されました
このことについて考えます
まずデータが圧縮できるということはデータを小さくできるところです
先ほど交差したパスカルの三角形は左右対称で左半分にあらゆる数字が右半分に同じ
ように現れます
従ってこの三角形を作るのに全ての数字データが必要ではなく左半分にある者だけで
十分です
左半分うちして
それは反転させて見に打つば作れる感じです
この場合もともデータが約半分に圧縮でくることになり
パス館参加型は高いデータは粛清を持つことになります
これは富士山の画像にも当てはまることです
富士山の左半分落ちして
それを反転させて meets ば
ほんまのとほぼ変わらない富士山の写真を作ることができます
よって富士山の画像のデータ圧縮性も高いと言え
このような画像が美しいと認識されることが研究で示されました
この写真のむしろいのは
富士山が湖に映っていて
上下対称にもなっていますね
美しさが増していると思いませんか
では
美しいと認識される画像のデータ圧縮性が高いことが示されたのですが
一般にどのような画像が高いデータ圧縮性を持つのでしょうか
先ほどの簡単な例からもわかるように
画像2数学的構造がある場合そのデータ圧縮性は高くなります
これは先ほど述べた研究において美しいと認識された画像の例です
この花は
ある数学的構造用いて非常に効率よく書かれておりデータ圧縮性がとても高いのですが
どのような数学て構造が使われていると思いますか
どうでしょ
実は先ほどこの構造を見ていたんですけどね
ここでは
フラットあるが使われています
こんなことを考えると
私たちが数学において探求するもの鳳凰像は
私たちが美しいと思うもの
またはそれに貢献するものであるということもできます
金ね行われた脳研究もこのことをしてしまう
久ます
このずに緑を示されている脳の部位
内側眼窩前頭皮質は
美しいと認識される風景
絵画音楽などに反応することで知られていたのですが
数学的概念構造に対しても同様に活性化することが分かりました
我々の脳にとって数学で探求する日は
自然や芸術における人共通するところがあります
時間となりましたが
数学は論理的概念の詩であ
数学者は
構造探求構造を作り出すものである
私たちは数学において美しいものを探求するといった数学の本質的な特徴は
おそらく皆さんにとって意外だったのではないでしょうか
また私たちが何を美しいと思うのかについて
新たな側面を見出していただけたのではないでしょうか
これから何か美しいものを見たとき
皆さんは数学のことを考えられるかもしれません
もしかしたら
それは大きな変化ではないでしょうか
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]